Hey everyone, how are you doing?
Ready to learn a bit about editing assets in the engine?
All right.
In this video, we'll be focusing on construction blueprint tools to edit assets in our maps.
Let's get right into it.
So we said construction blueprints, but those blueprints are actually just blueprint classes
or actors, and you can distinguish them in the content browser by their blue bars and
little thumbnails with a sphere on it.
We call them construction blueprints because they primarily work in the construction script
graph of our blueprint editor.
Now, keeping it simple, blueprint visual scripting is a node-based visual programming language
in Unreal Engine.
And before I said blueprint class, what is it?
A blueprint class, often referred to as blueprint, is just an asset that allows you to easily
wrap some functionality code into it.
This blueprint asset can be placed into maps and will behave like any other type of actor.
Now, the construction script specifically is a type of graph in a blueprint class that
executes when an actor is placed in the editor, meaning in our map, but not during gameplay.
It basically helps creating customizable tools that improve the artist's workflows.
And we will take a look at one of them in just a second.
You can also use construction blueprints in conjunction with procedurally generated content
or PCG that we will check out in the next video.
The construction blueprint we will review today is the BP-Crixle Spline scatter and
was extracted from a Crixle asset pack.
This specific construction blueprint will allow us to add assets along a spline.
So let's take a look at it in the engine.
So if we navigate a little bit higher here and towards the beach of this map, you can
see that if you click on this asset, it's actually a blueprint actor.
You can see the sphere up here.
Now if we take a look at its details, we can see down here that we have some meshes assigned
to this blueprint actor.
And those are the meshes that are actually in populating this spline.
Now this construction blueprint will be populated with the static mesh assets we input into
it just like here.
These assets will be instanced into our map.
What does instancing mean?
Instancing basically means that these assets will be copied but in a very specific way
because instancing helps efficiently group identical static meshes into one actor as
you can see here.
And this helps reducing performance and workflow costs.
So let's take a look at this spline.
If you click on this white squares here either at the beginning or the end of this spline
curve, you can either move them directly around into the map and this will either add or decrease
the amount of meshes you see populating our spline.
Or you can also, you see these little purple squares either here or here.
You can also move those and those are the tangents of the points of the spline.
And the points of the spline are the white squares while the tangents are the purple ones.
If you move around the tangents they will just be impacting the shape of the spline but not
the length of the spline directly.
In order to do that you will need to move the original white squares.
Okay, let's try to populate one of these construction blueprints from scratch.
So if you navigate into the content and blueprint folder you can find the blueprint quicksand
spline scatter tool down here.
And if we drag and drop it into our map you can see that we just get our spline.
Now we have it selected up here quicksand spline scatter tool.
And we can start selecting our meshes by clicking on this add element button here.
So let's start with some rock and anything will do.
I will just choose four different rocks now.
Okay, so now if we click on one of the two squares and we start extending it we can see
that the meshes will be randomly populated around our spline.
We can also just move our tangents around.
Now you can see that if you have one of the points selected you don't get access to the
static meshes or the rest of the details of your construction blueprint.
So make sure to select it directly into the outline in order to get access to these different
settings.
Now what else can we do here?
We can also bake these meshes to the level so we can access to them individually.
We can change how they're randomized along our spline.
We can choose the spacing between them, the random rotation.
You would probably need to add very high numbers here like 2000 and then the random scale.
You can also access to further additional transforms by pressing shift on the keyboard
and clicking on this little arrow here you will be able to expand all the different sections
of these nodes.
And here you can see that you get access to the individual location and node mesh of the
assets populating our spline.
Alright, so since we mentioned that I just want to show you really quickly what visual
scripting looks like.
So if I click on edit in blueprint up here in the details panel or here in the outliner,
I will be able to open my blueprint actor.
And here you can see that we have the event graph and the construction script.
We're not going to dive into visual scripting right now, but this was just to give you a
hint on how these tools are developed.
Now let's go back to our slides to conclude this video.
Alright, that was it for this class, but you can find some additional documentation at
this link if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge in blueprints, specifically
the construction script.
I'd also encourage you to take a look at our courses focused on blueprinting on our platform
because they will dive into this concept in great details.
Thanks for sticking around and in the upcoming lesson we will look into procedural content
generation and how to use it in our environment.
Bye!